thank you I have three sold out nights
this weekend one record-breaking concert
Taylor Swift and her era's tour has now
moved on to the next city bro the amount
of money this [__] is making on this
goddamn tour is insane oh yeah the
ticket prices are like no but I mean
there's certain people that she's huge
no no I'm with you but that's what's up
with the program next like
I get it Taylor Swift's very talents
people like her she's pretty blah blah
blah blah got it
but Taylor Swift
to me is the same as every one of these
other [__] what is it about her that
she's Mega popular and other ones have
trouble selling out the [__] Amway
arena you know like I don't get it
I mean marketing yeah
Swifty fan is still thinking about his
Wildest Dream Come True Brooke Rogers
explains how swift gifted him a moment
and a Memento that he will never forget
Jalen Ford stations himself on South
Cooper Street in Arlington
I hate him every day I hate him for
hours
giving drivers a break from their daily
tickets so he doesn't have a job he's
giving him a Break by what dancing like
a stupid [__] he's on welfare and
instead of doing anything like
productive
back in my day giving audiences a break
was called loitering
yeah right
everybody likes it I mean
and that includes finding a way to
secure the toughest ticket in town
Taylor Swift Ford's favorite almost
Swifty for real I love Taylor Swift it
was thanks to this community that Jalen
was even oh he's [__]
okay what's a little different if you're
[__] he's a buckeye no I didn't mean
like
Nature's retardation I mean like mental
retardation gay black guy
able to go to the concert more than a
hundred people donated to a GoFundMe
raising more than three thousand dollars
to make his dream of seeing Taylor Swift
in person so he got so he got half the
money he needed for Taylor Swift ticket
and the nosebleeds and the [__]
nosebleeds is what's happening
when I got to go you know it was just so
happy but the floor seat to Swift was
just the beginning toward the end of the
show security guards approached Ford and
kicked him out because he was too black
for a Taylor Swift concert I thought he
looked suspicious
him to come with them I thought I got in
trouble I just thought that something
happened
Scott
that's great I'm honestly turning around
on this guy and I thought I was at the
wrong seat as she's saying 22 Swift
walked right up to Ford and gave him her
hat son
doing what you squatting down and gave
me that hand that you grew with a kiss
it was just over it was just over like
my dream really came true I literally
couldn't that was your dream
my dream was to be nappy is be not be
[__] that would be my dream that was
[__] if I go to a Taylor Swift
concept uh concert and I leave with a
souvenir it's going to be it's Taylor
Swift
my dream is my dream is I get chased by
like it's like a Hitler but he's got
like my grandma's body and lobster hands
that he chases you'll never be perfect
that's a nightmare it's a real nightmare
he meant dream isn't like a goal yeah
I didn't sleep he says he's keeping the
hat at home and plans to put it in a
case
it'll be an upon shop in a couple weeks
he still doesn't know who coordinated
the surprise but he's great it was me it
was me Austin to [__] story two weeks
from now ah local guy gets robbed
like
thank you
you're the first time a white girl stole
from a black guy to get the Hat it's
going to be very easy to figure out that
this guy spends [__] five hours at
the same five hours a day dancing on the
highway it'll be very easy to break into
his one bedroom apartment it's like that
so you don't exactly need a [__]
crack team for that
but I mean you know just just in case
hear me out
I know it's coming I know it's coming
all right guys we gotta get Taylor
Swift's hat out of this bomb black
[__] guy's house I'm just gonna walk
in when he's not there oh
I'm Gonna Knock on his door and tell him
I'm his new best friend and then leave
me in and then I'll just oh my God
you're right and I won't even steal it
I'll ask him he'll feel bad and give it
to me
oh no you now I'm sad yeah you you know
you know Lloyd it would make me very
happy if I had your hat and here's your
hat
listen buddy so it turns out that Taylor
Swift has superpowers to keep her alive
and uh turns out that the powers were in
the Hat and she's slowly dying now
back to her if that's okay and he's like
oh my God you just leave yeah thank you
see here's the thing and then a weak
lady you run into him at like a [__]
Dairy Queen and he's like so what
happened to Taylor what happened to
Taylor and you're like what who and he's
like Taylor Swift and you're like oh
yeah she's fine have you seen the big
spoon blow it off occasion